We now would like to
generalize our concept of work
to the motion of
an object that goes
in more than one dimension.
And so, if we have
our object here.
And we're applying a force.
And the object is moving.
And let's say the path is a
little bit more complicated.
So our object, a little
bit later, has moved.
And we're going to
call that displacement.
We now want to
generalize our concept
to work to handle
this type of motion
in more than one dimension.
In order to do that, we'll need
a new mathematical operation,
which we're going to
call the scalar product.
So what I'd like to
do first, is define
this in terms of
vectors and then
we'll apply it to
the concept of work.
So suppose I have two vectors,
a, and another vector, b.
And they're separated
by an angle, theta.
And in this case,
our theta, we're
going to just take
it between 0 and pi.
Now, I'd like to talk about
how much one vector projects
in the direction of the other.
So if I call this the
parallel component of b.
Then I want to define a quantity
which we're going to call
the scalar product of a dot b.
Which is the
magnitude of a times
the amount of b that is in
the direction parallel to a.
From our geometric
diagram, you can
see that b parallel is
equal to the magnitude of b
times the cosine of theta.
Remember, theta's
going from 0 to pi.
So this quantity,
b parallel, can
both be positive or negative.
If theta is between 0 and
pi/2, then in that range,
the cosine goes from 1 to 0.
And this quantity, b, will
be greater or equal to 0.
b parallel.
If theta is going from
pi/2, theta to pi,
then we have that b parallel
is less than or equal to 0.
And, in particular,
at the value pi/2,
b parallel is 0 because
when theta is pi/2,
the b vector is completely
perpendicular to a.
And this is what
we're going to define
to be the scalar product.
But geometrically, we can
also look at-- let's draw
our pictures again-- a and b.
Let's consider how much
of the a is parallel to b.
So that's a parallel.
And if this is the
angle theta, we
see that a parallel--
and I'll write it
as a parallel-- is the magnitude
of a times cosine of theta.
And so, I can also
define a dot b
as equal to how much of
how much of a is parallel
to b times the magnitude of b.
In both of these
instances, because b
parallel is the magnitude
of b cosine theta,
and a parallel is a magnitude
of a cosine theta, what we're
writing is that a dot b is the
magnitude of a cosine theta
magnitude of b.
And now you can see that
this quantity is a parallel.
And this quantity is b parallel.
And this is our geometric
definition of a dot product.
One thing that we
want to consider
are two important
rules for dot products.
And they're the following.
That if we take a vector and
multiply a by a quantity-- c,
here, is a scalar
quantity-- then
this is equal to
c times a dot b.
Geometrically, this
is very easy to see.
Because if we draw
a and we draw b.
And if I multiply a by a
scalar, and let's make,
in this particular
picture, our scalar
bigger than 1, then the
new vector a is multiplied
by c and it's c times a.
The scalar product is just ca
dot b, is the magnitude of ca
times how much of b is parallel.
And when you multiply
this together,
you get c times a
times to b parallel.
c of a dot b is equal to c
times the magnitude of a times
b parallel.
And you can see that these
two expressions are equal.
If you multiply a dot
product by a scalar,
it satisfies this rule.
And there's one
other crucial rule
that we'll need when
we look at vectors.
That if you take a vector a
and you add to it, a vector b,
and you dotted in
a vector c, then
this is vector addition
and multiplication.
This vector addition distributes
over vector multiplication
by a dot c plus b dot c.
So these two facts are crucial
to our development of vectors.
One thing that we
can say is-- we'll
leave this as a little exercise
for you to prove this result.
It's a pretty straightforward
vector construction.
And to just give you a
little bit of a hint.
If we have a vector a
and another vector b
and we have a similar
vector c, then
if I draw the vector a
dot b plus b and I want
to take a dot c.
So I have how much of
a is parallel to c.
And if I look at how much
of b is parallel to c, then
as part of the exercise,
make sure that you
can see that how much of
a plus b parallel to c
agrees to this
distributive rule.
So these are our definition
of scalar product.
And the two key facts that
we'll need when we apply it
in our example of work.